Peter Desberg, author/screenwriter: Penultimate
questions.
Jeffrey Davis, author/screenwriter:: That’s
okay because she’s so adorable.
Peter: You know that we’re judging your
questions, right?
Film Courage: …That’s okay and I’m at
peace with that
Jeffrey: That’s good because I’m not.
Peter: Did you have enough carrot juice to
make you at peace with that?
Film Courage: Yes, I did actually have enough
carrot juice.
Jeffrey Davis: 92 references to carrot juice.
Film Courage: I actually have to go back and
get more.
I’m running low…what are some…[laughs].
Peter: See another multiple parter “what
are some?”
Go ahead.
Film Courage: What are some of the most important
questions a screenwriter can ask themselves
when developing a story idea?
Peter: How much is it worth?
[Laughs]
Jeffrey: A point for each, that doesn’t
get you to a hundred.
Peter: I think one important question is
how universal is it?
You know, you may be having the most esoteric
story but if it touches everybody it’s a
universal story.
If it’s very, very narrow, then it doesn’t.
So you’re always saying how are people going
to relate can anyone find something in this
relationship I’m creating, in this conflict
that I’m creating that they can recognize
something.
Film Courage: That’s why you asked the Mother-Daughter
premise for the book (Now That’s Funny)
because you figured most people can relate.
Jeffrey: It’s a generic old premise starting
with my sister Eileen.
Peter: Everybody has had a mother.
Jeffrey: I think it was chosen because you…
Peter: Well I don’t know your background?
Jeffrey: Because you could…
Peter: Poor teacher…
Jeffrey: Well she’s a child of a single
mother.
She told us if you’d been listening.
I have a slightly different take on that.
I believe in the Stephen Sondheim dictum that
the more personal a story is (and I don’t
mean autobiographical) that the more it matter
to you the most universal its going to be.
But both things are valid.
It depends on the writer.
I will tell you that if you try to write something
commercial you will fail every time.
For example, when DIE HARD was a success there
was one movie after another that came out
with that kind of…none of them was as good
as DIE HARD but for every movie that came
out like that (hero in a trapped place trying
to save the world - whatever that is).
Peter: With a sense of humor.
Jeffrey: With a sense of humor, that’s very
important.
There were hundreds of scripts that were written
that never saw the light of anywhere.
I believe you have to write what you want
to write.
Peter: Look at what “Go ahead, make my day”
did.
Everybody tried to compete with that.
Jeffrey: And that wasn’t a new concept when
it was written.
I mean BULLET worked (say concept).
BULLET was a more stylish cop.
The Dirty Harry movies were great.
They’re well made, they are kind of the
detective version of the spaghetti westerns.
Peter: But having the one key line at the
right moment.
Jeffrey: But today I don’t think one key
line is going to make a great movie.
I think it was the right actor at the right
time for the late sixties.
But I think the other thing you need is patience…well
all the things we’ve been talking about.
The ability to tolerate…
Peter: [Whispers] Ambiguity.
Jeffrey: What?
Jeffrey: Ambiguity.
He likes that word.
Nobody else understands it.
The need to tolerate failure.
The need to get up and try it the next day.
No writing career can ever be made on one
script.
I really believe that you’ve got to write
a lot and not judge it (we’ve talked of
all this before).
And then of course be willing to show your
work.
Film Courage: Not waiting ten years?
Jeffrey: If you’re just going to put your
work in the drawer and you’re just doing
it for your own pleasure, that’s fine.
But don’t say you want to be a professional
writer.
Peter: I’m waiting for the nineteen part
last question.
Film Courage: Well there was a follow-up to
something you said.
Jeffrey: Okay.
Peter: Oh, that’s so cheating!
Film Courage: And the follow-up is…
Peter: Penultimate part two?
Film Courage: You said that most films can
be based on or their popularity could be based
on one line…make my day or…
Jeffrey: You mean the hook?
Film Courage: Or “Frankly my dear, I don’t
give a damn.”
Something like that
Jeffrey: Yes, but that had nothing to do with
the plot of the movie, that’s just…
Peter: Character.
Jeffrey: That’s just character.
Film Courage: But you don’t feel that today?
Jeffrey: Well they want a hook, before they
want to hear the premise, before they want
to hear the story.
So in something we’re working on now we
used BACK TO THE FUTURE, the hook would be
a young boy goes back time to make sure his
parents get married so he’ll continue to
exist.
That’s terrible, I cant remember what we
used, that’s a hook, that’s not a premise,
yet.
It’s an idea for…so to me it’s an idea
for a story.
You still haven’t developed the story.
The thing you brought in about the two brothers
is much more developed by that.
Film Courage: But in terms of a line sort
of living on past the film.
Jeffrey: Oh, oh, you mean why do lines live
on past the film.
Film Courage: Are we beyond that?
Jeffrey: No I don’t think we’re ever beyond
that, I mean you get memorable lines as recently
as WHEN HARRY MET SALLY?
What’s the line?
Film Courage: “I’ll have what she’s
having.”
Jeffrey: Exactly, you know that line was improved,
it wasn’t even a scripted line.
That was Rob Reiner’s mom, that’s Carl
Reiner’s wife.
Film Courage: But wasn’t that from the nineties?
So anything today?
Jeffrey: Oh you’re saying now?
Yes!
There is one in a recent movie, I don’t
know have you guys seen GET OUT recently?
Film Courage: Not yet.
It’s on the list.
Peter: I think writers are always trying to
write those lines but they are usually really
self-conscious and awkward.
Jeffrey: This wasn’t because this was a
movie…the only thing I can tell you about
the movie, it was made for nothing and the
guy was famous before he made it, the director’s
wonderful, Jordan Peele.
He had that show on Comedy Central and he
knows everybody.
But this his directorial debut and the movie
wasn’t expected to do well and it was one
of the most successful movies of the year
and there is a great line in it that I think
will live on past the movie and that’s…the
premise is a white girl takes her black boyfriend
to meet the parents…that’s not what the
movie is about at all but that’s all I can
tell you or it will ruin the movie for you.
But the first thing the father says to the
black boyfriend who is actually played to
my wife’s consternation by a British actor
[Daniel Kaluuya], he says “You know I would
have voted for Obama for a third term.”
Now that line is brilliant, it’s also in
character, it has to do with the movie but
it’s so witty and it’s so true that like
liberals (embarrassed liberals) when they
want to say something good and they’re…it’s
part of what the movie is about that people
will…he said in an interview that he gets
that all the time from white liberals that
they wished he could have had a third term,
they are trying to show you how liberal they
are.
So I think Peter is right have those just
like “We’ll always have Paris.”
Peter: But it’s just bad when you see it
self-consciously written like I think I’ve
just written that line and [grimaces].
Jeffrey: Well hopefully you are a good enough
writer to see that and take it out.
The other thing that really bugs me in writing
is when the writer makes a reference that
obviously doesn’t belong in the period or
they are trying to be too contemporaneous,
they’re trying to be too hip, so they’ll
make a joke about something they’ll make
a joke about something nobody would have made
a joke about.
I see that all the time.
I’ve probably done it many times.
But again a great line is great, it’s great
for advertising, but it doesn’t make a great
movie.
There are so many lines in DIE HARD, but that’s
not why the movie is successful.
I have a theory about why that movie is unique
and successful.
He wasn’t there to save the world, he was
there to get his wife out of the building.
And that’s what made it human.
And a lot of these like SPEED which was a
big success which followed it was such a contrived
situation, a bus that if it goes below a certain
[speed limit] it will blow up.
I mean, come on?
And then they manipulate by having the old
trick which everybody has used of having their
partner hurt which raised the stakes, which
can work, it worked great for…oh come on…help
me out…for Lillian Hellman’s boyfriend
who was blacklisted…you know a great mystery
writer.
Peter: It’s been used in a zillion movies.
Jeffrey: Yeah, but who was it?
He was the guy who did it better than everybody,
the movie about the birds…you know where
there was something in the "The stuff that
dreams are made of,” a classic line that
we’ll always know and that’s from THE
MALTESE FALCON.
Film Courage: What line?
Peter: You know when he sees what’s inside
the bird, the stones or whatever, it’s the
MacGuffin that everybody has been looking
for and he says “Ah, the stuff that dreams
are made of.”
It’s great right?
And then the other line in that movie that
I love is “I’m not going over for you
sweetheart.”
Meaning I’m not going to jail for you.
I love that movie, it’s so well-written.
Dashiell Hammett…thank you for helping me
so much.
Peter: I’m always there for you.